Kirsten's in Aiken South Carolina hi
Kirsten how are you I'm great Dave hurry
is better than I deserve what's up I'm
actually my fiancee and I we have been
I've been looking a lot at your stuff
listening to podcast and you think I'm
going to play less than half on board
and I am trying really hard to get him
motivated and older then I am 28 how old
is he 36 when will you be getting
married I you know any random Saturday
that we decide we have you know two
small children and really just just
putting it off for no good reason
okay combined we share a house okay so
you're already you're already shacked up
you got kids everything your everything
but just got the piece of paper go get
married my gosh you know so they already
doing it all I mean my god so anyway so
your husband as of next week is not on
board but you just discovered all this
stuff and you have all this new
information that you didn't have six
months ago and he still has you've
consumed the considerable amount of this
information that he's not consumed yes
now so you can't expect him to come to
certain conclusions you're coming to
correct so how are we going to get him
to consume the information listening to
the podcast he's in the car that's why
we could trick him in other words we
could trap him and trick him in the car
that's possibility okay
another possibility is to put the kids
to bed turn off all the televisions and
the radios take his two hands in your
hands and look into his eyes and say
this matters a lot to me and if it
matters a lot to me and you don't do it
it's going to start to matter to you you
think he'd get the hint I think though
because he cares about you he loves you
right yes yes I think he
in his mind he says it'll take seven
years yeah because he's a genius but
he's a broke genius right so I don't
care what he says he's wrong you know
he's talking about he sucks at money he
has none his opinions invalid that's
true okay so it's not a bad guy it's
just you know we don't ask a fat people
five people about dieting all right so
that's what it comes down to so just sit
down and say baby this matters a lot to
me you and I are gonna get married next
week and we're going to Financial Peace
University they've gave us a wedding
gift because I'm gonna give you a
wedding gift why don't you go Financial
Peace University is my gift would you go
to the classroom can you get him to go
the class if I give it to you for free
yes I believe so
you better that's the condition of the
gift yes I can do that I got to tell you
if you go without him let me tell what's
gonna happen you're gonna kill him
you're gonna get madder
you're gonna get madder and madder and
madder it's not a good idea for you to
go by yourself you need to go with him
okay so get married and go to class hold
on I'll give you a copy of the I'll have
you sign up with Kelly she'll get you
all signed up we'll get you the one-year
membership for Financial Peace
University every dollar Plus
everything's online and you go to the
group locally there in your area ton um
all over South Carolina easy for you
guys to get into a class and lots of
wonderful churches there would welcome
you guys into the class so you hold on
I'll have Kelly sign you guys up